Russia is further escalating its war in
Ukraine Moscow is mobilizing 300 000
additional soldiers and talks about
using quote all military means including
the use of nuclear weapons also Moscow
is orchestrating four so-called
referendums to Annex four Ukrainian
provinces Western governments
unanimously condemned those sham
referendums but will countries like
Germany now finally send those heavy
weapons that Kiev needs to repel the
Russian aggression that's our topic
today on to the point
war in Ukraine is there still time to
de-escalate
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to to the point I'm
gerhalel first let me introduce today's
panel there's Professor Marina Henke
security and defense expert at the
Heritage School
then we have Moritz gartman Chief
reporter at the German politics monthly
Cicero he has lived in Russia for many
years and traveled to Ukraine only
recently
and Eileen matley an expert on German
and U.S defense policy at the German
Society for foreign policy
China's address to the nation on
Wednesday Putin has implied that he's
ready to use nuclear weapons even and is
it safe to say uh Marina let's start
with you that the chances to end this
war have just significantly dropped
well I think his entire speech signals
that he isn't ready to just give in
there was Hope on the Ukrainian side and
also on NATO's side that the
counter-offensive by the ukrainians
which was truly impressive by the way
would stop that war and bring Russia to
its knees or at least you know reduce
its will to fight and I think you know
like what we saw instead was that the
Hawks in Moscow won over and that Putin
now tries to push back but of course the
big question is you know does this
mobilization actually occur can he you
know get ready 300 000 more troops um I
have my doubts and you know like when it
comes to the use of nuclear weapons it
you know I'm convinced I do a lot of
research on nuclear weapons and it won't
actually change the fundamental dynamics
of this war tactical nuclear weapons
that he's mostly talking off or actually
you know only talking of are
psychological weapons and I think by now
the Ukrainian population and even the
Western population are kind of used to
this rhetoric and won't be that shocked
um or you know kind of like pushed into
submission that Russia is hoping for
well it's uh he also said at the very
end of his speech I'm not bluffing uh
isn't that what bluffers always say
yeah that's what I would say if you sit
at the poker table uh and you Bluff and
you say I'm not bluffing
this actually uh irritates or it should
irritate your counterparts and
I also think that we shouldn't
overestimate what he was saying about
the nuclear weapons basically he was
saying he was threatening this since
March when the West Was starting
heavily to heavily support the
ukrainians with the weapons but it
didn't happen and I have the hope he's
not the only to decide he has other
people who have also to give their
consent to the use of nuclear weapons I
hope other people will hinder him from
doing this I listened yesterday to U.S
President Joe Biden at the UN reacting
to Putin's speech
um Ali what do you make of Biden's
reaction to his speech yesterday it
wasn't very strong was it
well I think we should also see that in
context with other statements by Biden
and just recently Biden a couple of days
ago said in you know in the direction of
Putin don't do it don't do it don't do
it
I.E referring to the possible use of
nuclear weapons so I think the the US is
very they're determined in its in its
will to first off to further support
Ukraine and also to signal to Moscow not
to overstep the red line of using
nuclear weapons in order to to achieve
its goals now we've talked about this
speech by Vladimir Putin let's briefly
listen into what he actually said
especially about the mobilization
our partial mobilization means that only
reservists will be drafted and it's
those who have already served in the
Army who have specialized military
knowledge and experience those who are
newly drafted will undergo additional
military training
now Marina what does he gain with this
partial mobilization and what does it
mean well he potentially gets 300 000
new soldiers and that's a lot he has
been losing a lot are they soldiers or
are they just they're folks who have a
basic military training so at one point
you know so Russia has a conscription
system so all of them have undergone
some kind of training at some point but
of course and that's why you know like
it took so long to a certain degree to
have this partial mobilization because a
lot of Western commentators were saying
why isn't Putin doing this much sooner
they were actually anticipating such a
decision already around May when he
hasn't hit his big military parade but
he was still very hesitant and you know
like now and it I think it signals that
he um does realize that he is cornered
that you know like he's kind of losing
the battle that he needs to make a move
but you know like the you also saw that
there was there is a an opposition there
was an uprising of people you know uh
kind of protesting this move Google
searches of how to leave Russia and
one-way tickets uh you know skyrocketing
uh so you know why was Putin waiting so
long because he feared that there would
be this growing opposition and I think
to a certain degree this is what we're
seeing but you know like of course
um the security apparatus in Russia is
so powerful that I actually think they
can a nip it in the butt as they've done
before now this uh mobilization of 300
000 troops
um we just heard that they had some kind
of military training now they just
Cannon father
I think so I mean also what we have to
bear in mind is that those 300 000
reservists they will not immediately be
sent and deployed to the front lines
it'll take up you know a couple of
months actually for them to arrive there
and um as Marina just also pointed out
um while they have undergone basic
training they need to be retrained um
and also there's the question of
equipment adequate equipment and there's
a big question mark whether they will be
properly equipped in order to to
withstand the Ukrainian um
counter-offensive and I it's pretty
strong exactly and I think well I have
my doubts that they will be actual you
know like that they can be compared to
professional soldiers what I would like
to add is the question of motivation
so now you will have 300 000 people who
will basically be forced to go to war
it's a different type of people than
those who were already fighting we had
those troops from the donbas or Maine
from the from the donbass region who
were basically defending their region we
had a Russian professional
soldiers who were doing this for money
and now you will have people who are
forced to do this and there is a big
question mark as to where these people
are really motivated to fight
it just one follow-up how is this being
viewed in Russia
is mobilization well uh if I can speak
from the conversations from with friends
they're shocked because actually what I
wanted to add is that this mobilization
it's called partial mobilization by
Putin but if you look at the laws that
were passed in the state Duma it's a
general mobilization it leaves the door
open to really getting on the population
into into this war so people are really
asking themselves now should they leave
the country or not I I watched one man
on this Russian independent TV channel
dodged who was saying that this war is
not about me I won't go to war I think
this is very typical for how Russians
see this war because up to now this big
support uh for uh for the war in in
polls it was basically passive support
because Putin
didn't interfere into the Comfort zones
of the common people they said okay let
him do this war as long as I don't have
to go there but now the situation
changes of course and then you wanted to
say I just wanted to add that on the
other hand you have the ukrainians who
are highly motivated to defend their
country in comparison to you know those
reservists who have very low morale and
also low morale which we could already
witness in the sort of in the
professional branch of the Russian Armed
Forces now this is all happening now in
in after uh Ukraine actually made some
significant uh gains in in their counter
offensive Putin's speech has to be
regarded in that light let's have a look
at Ukrainian advance and the area they
have retaken
foreign
can see it
among there's strategically important
Railway Hub a kupiansk this could hurt
Putin's Supply Alliance further already
one of the Russian weak spots if Russia
loses more territory in Ukraine it will
increasingly look also like a massive
person of humiliation uh for Vladimir
Putin so how significant are these uh
gains these Advanced for Vladimir Putin
so I think
it's fairly small on that map but it's
actually you know thousands of square
kilometers but I think more than that it
just shows that the ukrainians are
capable of launching a very complex
campaign
and you know like prior to February 24th
and even the first couple weeks of that
war a lot of folks that ukrainians do
not have any military capabilities to
speak of and now they're you know taking
back you know the Fortified country from
from the Russians and so I think you
know like what it really signals that
the training that they have received
from various NATO Partners is working
and also that they can actually handle
very heavy and highly sophisticated
equipment and of course that you know
like sends a message that whatever you
know like the West has been doing and
isn't just you know like showering them
with this with the stuff but they can
actually put it to good use and that's
also you know like a different lesson
learned from what happened for example
in Afghanistan and Iraq and there are a
lot of you know military forces were
trained but then you know like when they
were actually asked to fight they didn't
fight but here you see the ukrainians
fighting now this these advances seem to
have also triggered these so called
referendums in the donbass and and other
regions what difference uh will these
referendums make well I think the
biggest difference and also we should
point out it's it's fake it will be
manipulated so it's not an actual
referendum that we will be witnessing
and I think the biggest difference for
from viewed from from Putin or from
Russia is that
should they be integrated into the
Russian Federation they will be regarded
as Russian territory and so if now
Ukraine ukrainians are will continue to
to launch counter offensives in order to
retake that territory Russia could be
compelled to to point out well now um
Ukraine is actually attacking Russian
territory which could then sort of give
him a pretext to further emasculate he
could also say once you've done once
he's done that uh he could also say okay
that's enough let's sit down and talk
well this is a difficult question I
would say that of course this could
happen in two or three weeks uh that
Russia could start like a Charming
offensive uh and of course this could
somehow be dangerous for the for public
opinion in the west because we maybe
Germany I can say for Germany we feel
some War fatigue yeah in Germany so
it looks like a poisoned offer from the
Russian side of course
yeah because I think the ukrainians are
not willing to actually take this
negotiation offer and for good reason
because the momentum is on their side
and what my colleague just said the
mobilization will take time probably at
least a month two months until we see
any soldiers have an impact on that
front and of course the ukrainians now
want to use that and push further and I
also think that actually in the United
States they are on Ukraine side and also
doubt that you know like kind of
negotiation now will lead to any
significant result and I think you know
like what we in Germany need to learn is
that only because we reach a settlement
doesn't mean that there is peace right
there can be a lot of violence after a
settlement and that is then you know an
Insurgency because there's so the
fighting will the fighting Spirit of the
Ukrainian people and not just in West
Ukraine but meanwhile also in large
swath of eastern Ukraine is so strong
that they will never accept any kind of
Russian occupation even if it's then
officially annexed by Russia do you
agree or what kind of scenario do you
see happening well I agree free and I I
just wanted to add that there's also the
matter of trust the ukrainians rightly
point out why should we trust anything
the Russians are saying or agreeing to
given what we or given the the behavior
that we've been witnessing since 2014
and that I would agree to it it'll also
be very difficult for Western leaders to
trust in anything that Putin and his and
his people will offer at negotiations
whenever and wherever they will take
place
um you mentioned uh Germany a little
earlier Germany has already delivered uh
weapons to Ukraine including heavy
weapons like Howard says but Kiev keeps
pushing for the Crown Jewel as well
Germany's famous main battle tank
leopard two but Germany is still
reluctant to set
The Leopard 2 is one of the best battle
tanks in the world the 1 500 horsepower
tank is extremely high tech and is at
the top of Ukraine's wish list but
Germany's largest governing party the
SPD and its Chancellor refused to
deliver at the same time however all
have short stresses Deutschland Germany
is ready to take on leading
responsibility for the security and
safety of our continent continents
how does this go together even the USA
and the EU have nothing against the
delivery of the leopard 2 to Kiev
today more than ever it is necessary
that Ukraine gets the military
capability it needs to defend itself
currently has more than
225 leopard twos which means it could
only deliver a few without jeopardizing
its defense readiness
but other NATO countries also have the
leopard 2 in their inventories and could
participate in deliveries which Germany
is the manufacturing country has so far
prevented
will the German government give in soon
indeed will the German government and
many other Western governments change
tack after uh Putin's most recent speech
I think so I think that's uh
our Chancellor Schultz will not be able
to withstand the pressure that's coming
from within his Coalition party but also
that is coming from from Western allies
and not least that the pressure that is
being exerted come from from Kiev and I
think there's also no logical reason to
to withhold the delivery of of leopard
two tanks so why why the reluctance
anyway they've sent in heavy weapons how
it says rocket launches and all that but
they do not want to send in the main
battle tank one of a very effective
weapon uh why
I have the feeling that uh not only
shorts but the West uh
all over
they wanted to leave room for our
negotiations with Putin so they
basically told Putin from the very
beginning and the months since the
beginning of the war that okay we could
also deliver this and that to Ukraine
but we are not doing this at this point
as long as you're not doing this or that
and so in this situation I would say
that the West basically told Russia that
as long as you don't Annex these
territories we won't go the next step of
escalation and this would be sending
Western tanks to Ukraine but my feeling
is and also Schultz said this Chancellor
Schultz after his last phone call with
Putin that uh a further step of
annexation of Ukrainian territory won't
be left unanswered so I would say that
after these referendums and probably the
annexation of these territories by
Russia we must see the delivery of
German or Western tanks to Ukraine so
most just said the reluctance was
basically the West trying to keep its
powder dry would you agree
well and you know of course from all
sides there's still this fear that um
certain you know red lines might be
crossed by the ukrainians and so that
they uh then you know would attack
Russian territory and that's why you
know like it's a long-range missiles
have been held back and to a certain
degree you know like these uh
um battle tanks they're very very fast
so they could be used you know I don't
think it will actually that's the that's
their ukrainian's attention but you know
they could be used for dash across the
border and they're very powerful
vehicles and with howitzers and you know
like other equipment that is there is
like much harder to move them you know
they can also be moved but it's you know
it takes much longer so I think that is
you know still this idea of like you
know we want to we want to control the
ukrainians because we are scared that
they might you know kind of cross these
red lines because in the big picture of
things NATO is of course still worried
about Russia I mean this is one of the
one of the most important points that uh
I've heard again and again again that
the west or NATO or Germany in this
particular case uh is afraid of becoming
part of this war party to this war is
that realistic and what does that even
mean
well first of I think that would mean
sending troops ourselves which we have
ruled out again and again and which I
think is prudent so in I mean yeah we
are well it is true we're not a party to
the conflict in the sense that we are
you know that we are sending our troops
however we're not a neutral party either
we stand by the side of Ukraine and have
been doing so from the very beginning
um so I think that's a sort of a
discussion that distracts from what's
really important and I think it's a
discussion that's mainly Guided by the
fear of
overstepping a red line as viewed and
dictated by by Russia and I think that's
not the sort of the guideline that we
should be following but rather what do
we need to do in order to help Ukraine
fight back Russia but the interesting
thing is by the way that Putin in his
last speech he basically changed the the
storyline of this conflict from Russia
is fighting Ukraine that has support
from the West to Russia is fighting the
collective West as he said so inside
Russia now the the elite uh the
political Elite and the propaganda the
TV shows they are telling the story
that's actually Russia is fighting the
collective West
that wants to destroy Russia but you
know I think we shouldn't be ashamed of
that this is a war of aggression Russia
marched into an independent sovereign
state which is Ukraine without any any
reason to do so apart from Taken in that
country because of you know like
aggressive intentions so I think it's
only fair then to come to the aid of
that country that is defending itself
but are you advocating that we go even
further
well I think we should be
very firm in our mission and our mission
is that we are defending a democracy
that was aggressed by an imperial power
uh so now to you know back off and say
oh the Russians were portraying there's
a battle of you know like the West
against us well the truth is you know
that you're helping a country that was
aggressed by Russia there's exactly one
nation that started this war and that is
Russia and so I think in this entire you
know like sometimes to be too Gentile
with Russian feelings is wrong again
party to this War uh many Germans fear
missiles over Berlin it's a realistic no
I think that's an overblown fear why I
don't want to Discount the sort of the
concerns that many people have seeing
that we are now witnessing a main
conventional war on European territory
however I don't think that it's
realistic and plausible to assume that
Russia will will you know will attack
either Germany or any other NATO country
um in in the near future however we
should definitely be on the lookout
which I think it is very important that
NATO is increasing its true troops on
the so-called Eastern Flank In order to
make sure that Putin understands to not
overstep a line or red line by um by
interfering with these countries by
attacking these countries
I want to come to my last question and
uh I'll ask that same question to you
each and every one of you
can the West actually still de-escalate
in this war
what I think actually is happening right
now is that India and China are
de-escalating that war right so we were
always like watching very closely what
was the Chinese and what was also you
know like the Indian another Global
South reaction and at the beginning of
the war you know like they were not
necessarily in it but they were
supporting Russia and what we saw in the
last week and even yesterday is that
China is now more and more publicly
stating we want negotiations right so
like they're not happy with Russian
moves and so was India will that have an
effect though I think it will because
basically the Russians the support you
know like that they have externally but
also what's happening in Ukraine and
internally maybe slowly is diminishing
and it will in one form or another lead
to a change what the change is I cannot
say but it's certainly not strengthening
Putin's hand
the only country that can de-escalate
the situation is Russia because Russia
started this war of aggression against
Ukraine so I wouldn't frame our or the
West's reaction as a further escalation
or answering an escalation with further
escalation and but that doesn't mean
that we if you know if the ukrainians
are willing and ready to to return to
the negotiating table that we shouldn't
support that move obviously we should if
Ukraine says it's time and if they're
sort of you know happy and content with
the with the territorial gains they have
achieved
I would say that we need to continue our
Stark support for Ukraine continue uh
delivering weapons but on the other hand
we should be very clear in our messages
towards Russia towards the people in
Russia that we are not fighting the
Russian people this is not a war to
destroy Russia as Putin puts it so these
are the two factors I think that are
very important and this is the only
thing that we can do
thank you all very much that's it uh for
this week's edition of to the point I
hope you found our discussion
interesting and if you're watching us on
YouTube please join the conversation
leave your thoughts in the comments
below we'd love to hear from you thanks
for watching see you next week on to the
point
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]